The User Library enables you to store your own custom assets, so you can use them for any project, current or upcoming.
Before you move on, create a new active container named Furniture.
Let's say you are in a situation where you need an asset that is not available in the Asset Library, nor in any external library.
You can still import that asset from a DCC app of your choice, rework it, adjust its components and its materials,
and then store it for later recall.
You'll find the User Library at the top level of the Asset Library.
The first time you access it, it should be mostly empty, even though it shows a few folders in this video.
If you'd like to store a new custom asset in there, start by importing it using the Import panel in the dock.
You have a few samples to choose from in the 112TM Basics FBX folder that's been provided to you.
I'll use the Chair Type A1 FBX file in this example.
Note the information that got added to the scene graph under the Furniture container.
You have an FBX Reference parent and a Mesh Object underneath it.
Select the FBX parent and find it in the scene, it's probably inside the main building at this stage.
Move it into the Cafe area to see it better.
It is ready to go into the User Library at this stage, but let's do one better.
Actually, you only need the mesh, so select it and note that it's slightly sunk onto ground.
Select the yellow center of the transformed gizmo and drag it slightly so that the chair is properly rounded on the floor of the cafe.
Find a nice wood material that you like and apply it to the chair.
Now you're ready to send it to the User Library.
The technique is simple.
All you need to do is select the mesh in the scene graph, right-click and choose Add to User Library.
If you check your User Library at this stage, you will find a new entry.
This means that now, you don't need the original chair anymore, you can delete it from the scene, along with the FBX Reference.
You can even delete the FBX file from the Import panel, since all you need now is to drag the new asset from the User Library into the scene.
Let's try another one with a table, such as the file named Table Type A1 FBX.
Use the same technique used before to relocate the table, adjust its position and its materials.
Select the table and send it to the User Library.
Again, you can delete the originals and just deal with the new entity from now on.
What's more, you can group assets to add variations.
For example, I could duplicate the chair around the table,
create another container below furniture named Table with two chairs,
and move the meshes into that container.
Before sending the container to the User Library, you need to be aware of one fact.
Even though the container itself is a non-renderable object, it has a pivot point or an origin point if you will.
By default, it is set to 0,0,0 when you create the container.
Obviously, it is far from the table and chairs in this case.
This would be a problem if you tried to place this piece of furniture once you add it to the User Library.
So you can relocate the pivot point of the container using Pivot Edit on the toolbar,
eyeball it to match the center of the table in X and Y.
Once you exit Pivot Edit mode, you can send the container to the User Library.
From this moment on, you can insert a collection of tables and chairs, as well as individual parts.
Keep in mind that these assets are saved to disk as physical files, this means you can copy them from one system to another.
By default, user libraries are saved to your Documents folder in the C drive, but that can be changed to InMotion preferences.
At any rate, custom assets are saved as .tmi files and can be easily copied from one system to the next.
If you'd like to try this out, you'll find the User Library folder provided to you in the zip archive you downloaded for this course.
Copy the two subfolders named Furniture and QT onto your own User Library folder on your C drive.
You will need to save your project and restart to InMotion, but once you do, you'll have a new set of furniture you can use to populate the cafe.
In the next video, we'll look at Path Animation.